her first professional role was starring
as Arya Stark in the HBO hit show Game
of Thrones before getting into acting
she wanted to be a dancer she also
launched a new social media app called
Daisy she's Maisie Williams and here's
my take on her top ten rules to success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be memorable advice would you give
for us fine creatives like us knowing
what it is about you that is infectious
and and being able to convey that to
people as soon as you meet them is so
important being memorable and and making
an impact is so important you know in so
that's true for so many different lines
of work and not just to look as an actor
but you have to do things to stand out
you can't play by the rules and I think
that yeah just knowing that you're good
enough and knowing that it's not because
of how good you are but it's just who
picks you to the post and you know
making sure that you stay on that path
to be that person rule number two don't
equal money with happiness now that you
have more money than let's assume your
other path where you may have been a
struggling dancer who does the money
bring extra happiness and contentment
and security or do you just say it's
irrelevant
um I think it definitely brings more
security for me and my family and for
everyone I don't I try to share that as
much as possible I like to be able to do
nice things but I think that they're not
worth anything if you're doing them on
your own I think the experiences are
about shared experiences so anytime that
I can really include people I think that
that's so important but happiness no I
don't think I'm it makes you more happy
I think the things that you get to do
make me happy but if I couldn't do them
I'm not really less happy and like I
just think it's amazing to be able to
provide for my family and for my mother
the way that they she provided for me
for so long
but that doesn't make her love me
anymore or it doesn't make me any
happier
it's just something amazing that comes
with you know giving up everything when
I was 12 and working for the last decade
nearly decade of my life and forfeiting
lots of friendships and lots of
opportunities that being you know a
teenager and what comes with that is
this paycheck which is a phenomenal and
um but I don't think that makes you any
happier rule number three do things
despite fear it's a more nervous when
the cameras say okay action time to go
get this at this time you've done it 20
times now we need to get it right what's
more nerve-wracking that or a TED talk
for 15 minutes in front of a thousand
people a TED talk why is that um I
didn't performing that's like in my
bones
and being able to switch that on and
like I can pretend to be like still and
calm and like focused and thoughtful and
that's what my entire job is on Game of
Thrones Aria is very calculated and she
can command a room by doing very little
and I understand that feeling and can
portray that and can convince people but
my hands are actually right now
so you can do that on a camera I'd be
super calm but on stage or yeah in a
simple little podcast with me you still
get a little nervous or anxious yeah and
I think it really is just the act of
like you know creating a character of
yeah pretending yeah you think and I
think people people do it all the time
people live their entire lives like
pretending to be someone better yeah
putting on a mask yeah people don't
really know who they are and you do that
for so long that you really lose touch
with it's who you are and I think you
know being able to do that so strongly
and so convincingly you know means I've
created a career from it but yeah it
when I strip that away and decide to
drop that like I am a very anxious
person I think the best like medicine I
was ever given was really just trying to
embrace it and stop trying to fight it
really and just accepting that that's
how I deal with things and not letting
it stop me from doing a TED talk I'm
still gonna go and do it even though it
means that I'm going to be you know
uncomfortable and probably make my
anxiety worse or do a play I did a play
for three months Hampstead Theatre here
in London was that nerve-wracking
completely an opening night I looked at
myself in the mirror was alone in my
dressing room and I outwardly said to
myself in the mirror what made you think
you could do this like set it myself
haha that's point out the best thing to
say well for the first met you know but
I just couldn't believe that like past
Maisie had thought that this would be an
amazing idea but then you have to stop
and breathe and realize that like I'm
not gonna let this hold me back from
doing the things I enjoy it cuz
ultimately I enjoy performing I enjoy
being on stage I enjoy that sort of
thing and I enjoy you know helping other
people and and I know that the words
that I wanted to say and my TED talk
could be inspiring to other people and I
want to do that and it's difficult but
it doesn't mean I shouldn't rule number
four get out
your comfort zone what would you say
your initial inspiration was for the app
Daisy well I mean it's always been a
problem with the industry that I've been
aware of and if I hadn't got the
opportunities that I did then I would
have been really stuck knowing how to
get in but in terms of like the actual
instigation dom was like we should make
an app and i would never have thought of
doing that on my own but yeah I guess
you know between me understanding the
industry and and his initiate initiate
an issue initiative we made it we made
it work and what advice would you give
to people just to get the most out of
the Daisy out networking that's like the
biggest tool within it and the most
important tool working with people who
are outside of your group working with
exciting people that you feel like I've
got to push you and like doing things
that are outside of your own comfort
zone and applying and to be a part of
something that you're really interested
in but maybe haven't done before and
take that time to learn and grow also if
you want to learn from other successful
women entrepreneurs check out my 2:54
girlboss series it's free the link is in
the description below become so skilled
so vigilant so flat-out fantastic at
what you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed there's a lot of man's world
out there but entrepreneurship is a
level playing field there's no rules
it's important for us to remember the
joy in what we do it's important to be
effective in our workplace but it's
important to cultivate the moments that
just bring us joy rule number five do
what you love and what drew me to
performing and creating I guess I'm the
youngest of four I'm growing up and
going to school like I was just always a
show like a real like I just love to
perform and I love to make people laugh
and even if that wasn't the expense of
my like I don't know my dignity like I
just wanted me people laugh I wanted it
many people were happy with like
performing and I was in school plays and
I used to go to dance classes and I
loved the performances of that and
something about being on the stage and
being watched in and and what I was
doing that would bring people happiness
that I've just always really enjoyed so
you know it's very different in film
because you don't have an audience that
are watching you when you like clapping
along with it's not like that but I
guess you know when it comes out and the
fans are so excited for it and just
knowing that it's gonna be enjoyed by
people that's what I love about
performing and creating rule number six
ask yourself difficult questions what
advice would you have for other young
women who maybe feel super anxious super
stressed out and paint themselves ask
himself why am I even here what advice
would you have for them or coaching or
guidance
I think to just slow everything down to
write things out - I mean I think it
really depends but I think like giving
yourself the there's lots of different
types of like therapy that you can go
and do mean a Seabee CBT or something
and that but if that's not ready for you
I think it's like just asking yourself
really really difficult questions like
questioning getting to the root like you
look further and further with it and
because like the answers are all there
and I think you're capable of finding
that on your own and ask yourself like
why do you make yourself feel like this
because no one else is doing that to you
know why and and like don't stop until
you've like cried every last year about
the reason why I keep picking yourself
and keep trying to understand it yeah
I'm still you know on my way to figuring
that sort of thing out I think
you know it it's definitely like just
like layers and layers of like you know
trying to understand that but I think
it's all within you rule number seven
find balance I've like worked solidly
for like two years at a time and like
just got from one job to the next to the
next to the next and I just like from
it's not good for me I don't know I
can't do that it makes me sad a little
bit only if I'm being honest and it's
not my son I'm grateful and I don't mean
to me it's just honest I just you know I
said not I need to have a break
sometimes and what's been really nice
about starting Daisy is like I've
achieved all of this with my career and
now I'm so excited about having a 95 job
in an office there's actually really
lovely and I think having yeah just the
balance between those two is really
important just what I learn from myself
like you know it's very exciting being
offered in like these roles but if
you're jeopardizing like how you feel to
like keep going and keep working you
know I just don't think it's worth it
and I am in the position now where I can
pick and choose and choose to spend some
of my time seeing my family rule number
eight refuse to hold yourself back well
I left school about seven years ago I
made it my mission to continue learning
even though I never wanted to set foot
in a classroom again who knows what's
going to happen to my life in the next
10 years I surely have no idea I've
never had an end goal it's working out
okay so far so trust that you're good
enough if there's one thing that I've
learned is that there truly is a place
for everyone ask questions and laugh in
the face of people who say that they're
stupid questions be open to learning and
admitting when you don't know what the
hell is going on refuse to hold yourself
back and dare to dream big rule number
nine ignore the opinions of others I
have
tendency to judge myself based on other
people's opinions of me and that's sort
of where a lot of my anxieties have
always been and something that I'm
trying to change but I don't know you
know one year of doing that isn't going
to solve that and so I think you know
now with the show ending and moving
forwards into my life and I'm deciding
what I want to do I just worry that if
people are very vocal about what they
think on my life that it might affect me
even if it just upsets name like that
kind of scares me because when I get
upset
it makes me just forget a lot of the
things that I've worked so hard to try
and understand it's what that energy on
that upset or people's opinion exactly
as opposed to the good things you've
done yeah or your mission or what you
want to create yeah and that's when it
starts creeping back here and you know
it's like one not calm one thing you
read and then it can just spiral and I
know that I'm still very capable of
doing that so it's just that's what my
biggest fear is for the future because I
don't want it to stop me from doing
things I want to do yeah but other
people's opinions do opinions do still
or like really affect me
I'm rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip is have fun
hey everyone it's Maisie Williams here
HBO we're generous enough to give us
some of their game with her and swag so
today I've come to a local lumber store
to give away to some perspective
I'm now you're right
hello what can we give away you want
this one you know I'm Lorraine what do
you think I'm this yeah this is a little
boy hi I'm Lorraine hey I recognize you
from Game of Thrones right wow I've
never seen I heard it's a really good
show this character I recognize you
where do I know you from
always England no tinder no no what you
want a win today because by the way we
don't just give it for free you have to
do something first hello you have to act
out a scene from this Game of Thrones
okay you're gonna walk in front of me
just like you're ringing that back okay
let's do this shame shame yeah yeah I'm
throwing stuff at her now I've got a
special bonus clip from Macy on how to
find inner peace that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watch the video to
taking action here we go question number
one what do you need to do despite your
fears number two whose opinions do you
need to stop listening to and number
three what does balance looked like for
you you had the biggest show you know
you're getting on the cover of magazines
you have all these opportunities tons of
people are loving you but on the inside
you weren't loving yourself to sound
like what would have to change on the
external world for that free to shift I
think that was the point was that I was
waiting for something on the outside
world to change and it wasn't ever
really going to so I think it was
important for me to find peace within
myself I think I you know had a lot of
like Rocky
relationships with friends and and you
know my family you know had a lot of
thoughts about you know why did I get
this success you know next to like my
siblings and you know how much the guilt
or things you might have felt yeah
definitely and so I think what I needed
to do was start punishing myself for
that and that was what it came out as I
would punish myself for being successful
if you want to see the top 10 I did on
Kit Harington check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
you know I was a row rugby I was playing
quite a high level I can't stand
watching watching Thrones and knowing
it's a stuntman that's doing my bit so
anytime